♪ Ya, okay it's Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Sippin' in the P ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Puttin' out all my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Michael make the flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Yo, good morning.
We're back.
We are back after a little hiatus.
I've missed you, I'm sorry.
Is this a little bit,
I don't know the curtains,
(mumble) whatever.
Hope everybody's super well,
(mumbles) coming in.
The tea is here and we are on
with Tea with GaryVee.
Super excited on the Tuesday morning
and let's get right into it.
I've dusted on ones and twos
and today's a huge day.
We have a monster thing coming out.
I'll be probably looking at my phone
a little bit here during the show
because something's about to launch
on the internet that's gonna
make your head explode,
and I am working on it feverishly
and so I'm a little distracted
a little bit more than normal.
Please bear with me because
there's breaking news,
but I didn't want to cancel today's show
because we've been gone
for Friday and Monday
and so I wanted to get back.
So let's get into it, Dustin.
Let's get right into it. (slurps tea)
- What's up, gang?
- How are you?
Good, how are things?
- Long time, it's good to see you.
- Man, so listen.
One of the things that
we've done at our company
is we put together...
I wanna give you a little context
before I answer my question.
We put together a model
of Coronavirus buying decision-making
amongst 150 to 200 million consumers,
and we put it together, this data,
over the last few days to see why people
are making purchasing decisions.
- Okay.
- And, one thing we found
in the last four weeks
is a complete skip, a
complete jump from anything we
had seen in the last 10
years where people are buying
for three reasons only right now.
Helping others, safety and trust.
Over the last few years,
you've seen this as well,
significance, acquiring wealth,
showing how great you are,
those were a lot of the
key buying decisions,
purchasing decisions
that buyers were making.
And it's completely flip-flopped,
and so there are a lot of
business owners right now
who've built their business
over the last few years
on trust, safety and helping others,
and they haven't gotten traction.
And so, I'm super curious from you,
what do you tell business
owners 'cause it feels like
this is their moment.
- Offense, if they can deliver it, right?
A lot of people built their, you know,
on trust or things that
nature and don't have
the logistics or the infrastructure
to actually take advantage of it,
given the nature of whatever they sell.
So, you know, to me, the
answer during good times
and the answer during bad
times, challenging times,
opportunistic times is always offense.
Offense comes in the
form of communication.
Communication comes in
the form of advertising
or original content or
acting like a media company.
So, you know, to me,
I'm seeing a lot of
the similar trends, Phil,
and I'm watching pe-, for example,
I have friends who are like,
"My (mumble) is up 2x,"
because they have a
trust-oriented soap or something,
and I'm like, "How's your behavior?"
And they're like, "What do you mean?"
I'm like, "Are you spending?"
They're like, "Yeah,
we're converting better
"than ever on Facebook and Instagram,"
'cause a lot of people
pulled out their ads
'cause their businesses are bad.
- Right (mumbles)
- And I'm like, "Why are
you not 7x'ing your spend
"if you have the mon-,"
like, people are, you know,
you gotta know when to strike.
You know, I've only had
one real obvious moment
in my career where all my savings came...
I had all my savings,
I didn't make a lot of money building
my dad's business for him,
but I didn't spend any money.
I lived in a shitty
apartment and just saved,
and I had this moment
where I just believed
in social media, and I saw
Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr,
and I spent all my money on
investing in those companies.
And I remembered at the time I was like,
"Should I have held
back 20% of my savings?"
things that nature, but it
was black and white to me.
- Yeah.
- And if I had held back those 20%,
that would have been millions and millions
and millions of dollars lost.
And so, it's funny when you
were telling that story,
that's when I went back to that moment.
If you've got a business
that was built on that,
if you're seeing the traction,
you're not just watching
this video and you're like,
"Oh, okay, let me spend all of my money."
Just seeing the indications of traction
'cause you have the ability to execute,
you have to go all in.
- Yeah, and so I totally agree.
You know, I'll give you
another one of the data points
that I'd really like to get your feedback
on through your community,
which is the platforms that
people are going to right now
on digital it's Facebook,
Instagram and YouTube.
And weirdly enough, well actually it's not
'cause that where you get new is Twitter.
It's actually a pretty decent platform
to advertise on right now.
But here's the crazy thing,
25% of all Americans right now
making purchasing decisions
are watching local news
and consuming local,
you know, newspapers, local whatever.
That is equal to what
everybody is watching
on the cable news networks right now.
So 25% of America are watching
the cable news networks,
and 25% of America is just focused
on traditional, local news.
And I know you always talk about this,
about how their efficiency
sometimes in local TV,
local and traditional advertising.
It feels like this is one
of those moments, as well.
- The debate there is...
so I understand that, like, even for me,
I have local two, four
and seven on quite a bit
because there's a little bit of a warmth
of a face that you've known
for 34 years delivering it.
To me, the question is the commercials.
You know, what is happening
to our commercial time
because we're seeing a
lot of interesting things
during bigger TV events
right now where the social,
like we've been watching last month,
and the social spike
going commercial times,
you know, as soon as the
President's briefing,
or breaking news, or Fauci speaking,
or, you know, Cuomo's on.
We're seeing a ton of massive spikes.
I think we now live in
a world of consuming
the main thing--
- Yes.
- And then immediately going here
and giving our two cents,
which inevitably means
the commercial's having a
harder time penetrating us.
And so, yes, there's
definitely always efficiencies.
We're seeing a lot of similar things.
My question is, I'm always
trying to get people
to separate the content
from the commercial.
- Correct.
- So, Phil, it's great to see you, man.
I hope everything's well.
- (mumbles) it's good seeing you.
- Take care.
Let's keep it going.
Lot of interesting stuff
going on out there.
Andrew.
- Whoa, what's up?
- What's good, man?
- Hey, Gary.
So before I ask my question,
I was on Planet of the Apps.
So it was me and my two business partners,
and I wasn't on the show
because they only wanted two people,
but I was evolved the calorie tracking app
with your voice.
- Oh, get out of here.
- Yeah, and I remember you yelled at them
for playing rock, paper, scissors live.
(laughs)
So that was me and I was super bummed
that we didn't get to you,
but yeah and 'cause I
didn't get to meet you
'cause they're really strict,
but, you know, patience.
Finally meet you three years later.
- Yo, yo, it's a real pleasure man.
- So, my question is this.
My last company, the one that was
on Planet of the Apps,
ultimately ended up not working.
It was my first start-up.
I'm a software engineer.
We raised two million dollars,
made a bunch of marketing mistakes.
So, now I'm actually
working on a new project
that I'm really passionate about.
It's a travel subscription app.
I was supposed to launch last month.
So now, my question for you is,
when would you launch, number one?
And, number two, I wanna spend
the marketing dollars right this time.
I have like a smaller budget, 20 to 50 k.
How would you market a
travel subscription app?
And I'm thinking it's geared
towards millennials, mostly,
but that's kinda where I'm stuck with.
- How much does it cost?
- 99 bucks a month.
- So I would probably, I would spend
the marketing on Facebook,
and I would target
upper-millennial, you know,
high net-worth individuals
'cause $99 a month
subscription is a real number.
- Right.
- And so you need people
to actually have money.
It's 1,200 bucks a year.
So I would go very high-end Facebook.
I would launch it minimally 100 days
after things went back to normal,
whether that's three months, six months.
You need a hundred days of data,
like, I'm very concerned.
People are scared.
- Yeah.
That's what I'm worried about.
- Humans, by nature, are very capable
of being fear-based.
I mean, on a good day,
I can't see travel...
If everything goes well,
travel should be down 20%.
- Right.
- 'Cause there's a bunch of people like,
"I'm not traveling, the
Corona's gonna come back."
You know?
- Yeah, that's right.
So, that's what I was thinking, too.
So assuming things go back
to normal in May or June,
you would think minimum
at least three months?
- Minimum, because May and June,
the way I think about it
is September becomes normal
because May, June, July,
August is, like, staggered.
- Right.
- I mean, I think you need
to be mentally prepared
that you might have to wait to...
You might have to wait here a little bit.
- That's what I was thinking.
- I mean, maybe,
I don't know.
I feel like maybe November 1st,
maybe January 15th, in that range.
It would be my guess.
If I was to partner
right now, I'd be like,
"Hey, let's mentally
prepare for that range."
- Okay, cool, and then Facebook.
- Facebook, Facebook ads
targeting toward people
that travel, and then what I would also do
is give away a tenth of a
point up to three points
of the company.
So 30, big time, 2, 3, 4 million followers
on Instagram travel people.
And I'd give them a tenth
of a point of the company
in advisory shares in
exchange for a real promotion
around the app.
- Right, awesome.
Thank you so much.
- Andrew, that's a really important point.
I wanna make sure you grasp that one.
By giving up three points of your company,
which is three percent of zero at first.
With such a small budget,
it can really be the match
that gets your business going.
And there are some significantly
large travel influencers
on Instagram that are
gonna be definitely worth
the tenth a point, and
they've never owned a piece
of a company for their work.
So they're gonna over-deliver
for what you're giving them in return.
I think it's a big and
important part of your strategy.
- Awesome, thank you so much, Gary.
- Awesome, take care.
Stay well.
- Later, bye.
- Let me give a shout
out, Lori J. on Facebook,
what's good?
Howie B., what's good?
John Rawlings, what's good?
Good to see everybody this morning.
Bren and Dunne, Regime,
let's keep it goin', Dust.
Good to see you, Megan.
Josh, what's good?
- Hey, how you doing, Gary?
- I'm well, how can I help you?
- So basically, you
know, it's pretty simple.
So basically, I grew up in a family
that all I ever knew was, "No."
And basically, my family was always just,
"This is just enough."
So basically, I like to over-achieve
and I basically have two jobs, now.
And anytime I talk to
anybody in my family,
they tell me I'm doing too much.
I don't know what to do
now, like, basically,
I'm stuck, you know?
I have two jobs, sometimes three,
depending what I'm doing that week,
and I'm an essential worker.
I work for Uber Eats and
I work for Gold Buff,
and just, I don't know what to do now.
- What do you mean you
don't know what to do?
You, like, believe them
that you're doing too much?
- No, I don't.
You know, I'm the only
one that over-achieves.
Besides all of them, you
know, I make enough money,
I'm satisfied where I am now.
But I wanna know what I could do next?
Like, I feel stuck, you know?
- Well, what are you aiming for?
- Well, I eventually do wanna start
a YouTube channel, basically.
I feel like I have enough
content around what I do
in order to make YouTube.
But every time, like, for example,
at the beginning of this year,
I just got my car back.
Then I was homeless for a little bit,
so we just got back into a new house
back at the beginning of this month.
So basically, I'm building slowly,
but every time I get towards my goal
something else pops up, you know?
- Well, let's take a step back.
What makes you happy?
- What makes me happy?
Well, I'll be honest,
my son makes me very happy.
- That's awesome, man.
- Yeah, my son makes me very happy.
- How old is he?
- You know, besides that.
He is about to be seven in May.
- That's amazing.
Okay.
- So basically though,
basically everything we do,
me and my girlfriend, everything we do
is based off of him.
You know, we live for him, basically.
And, you know, basically, for example,
we promised him a PlayStation,
and still to this day we're
still trying to get that
because something else always comes up,
and we're always trying
to battle through that.
- Well, a couple things.
We're gonna do two things.
One, you're gonna email me
and I'm gonna send you
a PlayStation for him.
- Okay.
- That's gonna happen right now.
- As soon as you hang up, email me
at Gary VaynerMedia and
I'll get you a PlayStation.
Two, you're gonna try not
to make things with him,
let me rephrase,
you get to parent the
way you wanna parent.
One, I'm gonna get you the PlayStation.
So, good, the little
man's got a PlayStation.
Two, my recommendation,
one man's point of view,
you know how to parent, you do your thing.
I don't think goals
should be around stuff.
- Okay.
- Because you're training
him to put things
on a pedestal, right?
- You're right.
- You know how I talk
a lot about keeping up
with the Joneses, like, you
know how I'm always scared
that people want a BMW.
I think it starts early.
I think when you make
stuff, like the North Star,
and it makes sense to
me when I hear homeless,
struggle, you know, when
I hear all that, right?
I'm hearing you're the
only one over-achieving
and you're going through the grind,
so I'm like, "Fuck man, this
guy came from the dirt."
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- So I've got a lot of respect for you.
And I know that when people
come from that place,
stuff is on a pedestal.
You know, when you've got nothing,
and TV and then the internet
is showing you stuff
and you want that, but
I also think that leads
to enormous amounts of unhappiness.
- No, your 100% right, you know, I...
You're 100% right.
All I ever wanted was the nicest cars
and showing off to everybody else,
but eventually I started to overgrow that
once I became homeless for a little bit
with my girlfriend and my son.
I overgrew that very quickly,
and I realized that pride--
- Yeah, that humility.
- Doesn't get you anywhere,
because at the end of the day...
I wanna make sure your
son doesn't get caught.
He was seven, six when
he felt homelessness.
He's now gonna put a
PlayStation on a pedestal.
That's okay though, like, he's gonna have
that happiness, that's good.
But I think he's super early,
by the way, you're super early to flip
the script on fuck stuff.
That may also be the unlock
to you feeling stuck.
If you go for happiness, for the process,
then all of a sudden, like, it's crazy.
I know people don't
believe me when I'm like,
"I don't care about all the...
"I love my games so much I
don't care about all the stuff."
They're like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"You're about that money,
you're happy, you got that..."
Like, they don't understand,
they really don't.
I'm telling you the truth, my man.
They don't understand.
When you just love what you're doing
and you love the people around you
when you're doing it, you've won.
And so, I think you,
I wanna make sure you're not stuck
because you're trying to
figure out how to maintain
a roof over your head
and then start something
that may make enough money to go at it,
based on the car and the
PlayStation and stuff.
I don't want you to do that.
I want you to take a step back
and really think about, like,
what you like doing and
how do you just not give
a shit about stuff.
I'm telling you right now, man.
If you can really, like,
when you were homeless
you didn't give a fuck
about that stuff because, you
know, you were at that place
where you're like,
"Fuck it, I need a roof," right?
- You are right.
- But now that you've got the roof,
you know what starts trickling in,
you're like, "Let me put
some stuff in this roof."
- Mm-hmm.
- I want you to fight that.
You're still early enough,
but I definitely want you
to fight it for the kid.
- Like, you know, basically,
we literally still sleep
on the air mattress, you
know, straight from the grind,
straight from the muscle,
you know what I mean.
We are doing it from
the bottom to the top,
tryna make everything possible, you know?
I'm outside working every
day, six to eight hours
and sometimes even more
if we need to, you know?
- Yeah, I mean, look,
I'll be honest with you.
Six to eight hours is not
a lot of time of work,
I mean that with, like,
all the respect and love.
- And you're right.
- I know I'm right.
But I think that you're coming
from such a place, right?
That like, I'm listening, right?
"Over-achieving, this is where I'm at,
"six to eight hours."
I'm like, "Man," again, I'm like,
"Okay, this guy really, really got raised
"in an environment that demonized work,
"or demonized success,
or, like, played it safe,
"or were fearful or many other
things that I don't know,"
we're just trying to get on here.
But, let me tell you something.
Like, when you're on the air mattress
and borderline on in and out
of, like, being homeless,
I promise you, and this is
from the love, place of the,
I think you got a good sense of me,
this is coming from straight love.
Josh, six to eight hours ain't shit.
I think you come from a--
- See, you're right
and, you know, I can't see--
- Go ahead, go ahead, please.
- So basically, I was
raised by my grandparents.
My mom said that at three months old,
I cried way too much.
She handed me right off.
So my grandparents basically raised me,
and both of them, since
the age of about 45,
lived off of Social Security and SSI.
They never wanted to
over-achieve or risk that
because they didn't know
what was beyond that.
So basically, they always
shelter me in a little cocoon
to try to, like, hide me
away from life, you know?
So basically, I didn't
have no real childhood.
I'm trying to show my son
a real childhood, now,
because I didn't have that.
I didn't get to go out and
have fun with my friends,
'cause I wasn't allowed to have friends,
and I wasn't allowed to go
outside and play off the block
because I could get hurt.
I was always safe.
And basically, everybody
else that I'm around,
basically, my cousins who
all grew up in the same age,
I'm the only one that's
doing something with my life,
or trying to do something.
Because everybody else is just
trying to just stay at zero.
- I got it.
Listen, one of the great
things that ever happened to me
was I went to a really
under-performing academic college
(mumbles) and it was this world, man.
Imagine me, surrounded by people
who wanna figure out how
to trick the government
to let them not work.
Or coming from really adverse,
you know, I came from some adverse shit,
but, like, very quickly
there was stability
and then prosperity started to grow.
You know, like, people are
coming from grinds, dirt,
and, like, I was in that
world for four years
and that was my friend base
and that was my society,
that was my culture.
And besides being an empath,
I was really in the
front lines of it, right?
And so, I don't judge you, right, like,
I'm reading the comments
and everyone's like,
"This mother fucker, six to eight hours,
"that ain't even a full day,"
you know, and I understand
where they're coming from.
- Of course.
- On the flip side, I really understand
where you're coming from.
I think you need to hear,
you know, more ambition.
I think you need to download
15 to 20, you know, podcasts,
and just listen to ambition 24/7.
24/7 ambition in your ears.
Because, what's happening
is, you're comparing yourself
to people that have zero ambition.
And so, you think you're over-achieving
at six to eight hours,
and then when we got through this talk,
we're like, "Whoa, you're
not even starting."
- Of course.
- And that's good, there's
nothing wrong with that.
Who gives a (mumbles)
Josh, step number one, and this
is for everybody out there,
anybody who's in a predicament,
step number one is fuck yesterday.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if you
worked zero hours, six, four,
your grandparents, your
mom, you know, abandonment,
that's the worst, your grandpa, like,
you can sit and dwell and explain to me,
your girl, your little guy,
you could explain to the world
why you didn't, or,
you can say, "I had this
fucking 10 minutes with Gary,
"I'm deciding to look a different way,
"and I'm so goddamned young,"
which you are, how old are you?
- 25.
- You're a baby.
- You're right, you know what I mean.
But you need to put 24 hours a
day of ambition in your ears.
Don't let that become delusion,
don't make it about the money,
make it about the
process of getting happy,
which also has the chance
of bringing you value
financially, potentially.
But if you go for happiness,
like, there's just so
many things that stood out
from this call with me,
one, just the way you talked about...
Like, the way you smiled
when you said, "Your son,"
I already knew we were good.
But then, also, the
delusion that you think
six to eight hours is going at it,
I'm like, "Okay, this guy
is really in that cocoon.
"We gotta pull him the fuck out."
Josh, I'm trying to pull you the fuck out.
Like, bro, I work six to
eight hours as a hobby
before I go into work.
- See, and that's the
thing, you know what I mean,
that's why I wanted to talk to you
because basically, like I
said, I'm stuck, you know.
Basically, six to eight hours,
I work six to eight hours
because basically,
those are only hot times
to make good money.
- No, that's only good
hot times to make money
on driving Uber Eats.
- Yup.
- What you could do is soon as you're done
with the last fuckin'
delivery of some fuckin' pizza
is go to Goodwill and spend $18 bucks,
find some shit, post it
that night and make $88.
- Oh, yeah, and that's another thing, too.
I really like to resell things, like,
I'm really good at that.
- Not, no you don't.
You like the thought of it.
If you liked it--
- Yeah.
- the way I like it,
you'd do it 24/7.
I used to fuckin' work 13 hours a day
at my dad's liquor store,
then come home and post on eBay.
That's called like.
You like the idea of it.
You don't like it because work ethic
isn't fuckin' in your blood, yet.
Anything could be taught.
You know how many muscles I had?
Zero, fuckin' six years ago.
Then I finally got it into my system
and now I workout.
I mean, I thought I could never be healthy
in my workout regimen.
I hate it.
I still hate it.
But I got over the hoop where
I made it palpable enough
'cause I know it matters.
You need to fuckin' learn to love work.
- All right, sounds good.
- I like where your eyes just went.
You understand, not I'm gonna
use work to get that money
'cause you understand
you gotta get out of it.
No, you have to love it
so you do it every fuckin' minute.
And then you gotta it back it back out
and balance with the son and
the girlfriend and all that,
but, like, you need to
find something you love.
Call it like--
- I can do that.
- because you don't like the flip life,
you like the idea of it.
- You're right.
- Everybody loves entrepreneurship.
Not anymore now that it's hard.
I'm getting all sorts of
crazy emails and dm's.
I look at their accounts.
They were flexin' entrepreneur life,
bottles at the fuckin' club,
like, "Yo, entrepreneur life."
Now they're crying to me
because they don't know
what the fuck to do.
They didn't love it.
They loved the fuckin'
picture for the 'Gram.
- Mm-hmm.
- They loved the 2 A.M. fuckin' party
that they'll never forget.
They forgot.
That shit's distant history.
Now they're fuckin' scared.
You know why?
'Cause all their fuckin' self-esteem
is wrapped up in being
a fuckin' entrepreneur,
and now they're gonna have
to work at fuckin' Chase Bank
'cause their direct-to-consumer
T-shirt business is fucked.
- That's true.
- Because they spent fuckin'
$1400 on a bottle of Grey Goose
trying to get that girl instead
of putting it in the bank.
That's what they did.
What you need to do is realize yours
is a little bit different.
You just don't have that
relationship with work.
- See, I never really had
that relationship with work.
Like I said, me basically
coming from nothing
and just trynna build,
I'm trynna find my way
around but I'll be honest
with you, Gary, I've pretty
much limited mostly anything
I could do due to my body tatoos.
I do get looked at differently.
- Good news.
That is the bullshitest,
bullshit excuse of all time.
- How's that?
- If you think that 2020,
I'll tell you.
If you think that, it's not 1974, bro.
- You're right, it just, you
know, I went to a job interview
like two weeks ago, for example,
and he looked at me like I was crazy.
- Fuck that, that's one fuckin' job, bro.
- Bro, that's one job.
- You're right.
- That's one job.
You know how many fuckin'
clients don't hire VaynerMedia
because I curse?
Straight talk, you know
how many big companies
don't hire us because
I'm on LinkedIn like,
"I'm gonna fuck..."
You know, they're like, "Fuck that."
But that's one.
- You're right.
- Bro, I promise you.
You can get any,
where do you live?
- Philadelphia.
- Bro, you could get any
job at any coffee shop
or fuckin' cool fuckin'
bar in Philadelphia
'cause you look the part,
instead of the reverse.
They want your neck tattoo.
- You're right.
- A hot fashion brand wants your tattoo.
Fuckin' hip hop brand?
Wants your tattoo.
If you go into some stodgy-ass
fuckin' company, fine.
But that's you setting up
for the L so you can use
the excuse of a tattoo.
Don't fuckin'...
You know me, I'm not
gettin' tricked out here.
- I got you.
- You understand?
- Yeah, I'm gonna go out
there, I'm gonna give it 100.
- It's 2020.
I judge people who wear suits and a tie
more than somebody who's got a fuckin' tat
of a fuckin' eye drop
on their fuckin' face.
It's 2020, bro.
- I dig it.
I'm gonna give it 100, Gary, I promise.
- Listen to me.
Your little man needs this from you.
You need to show him.
I'm gonna send you that PlayStation
'cause I promised and I want him
to be fuckin' happy as fuck.
But then, on the flip side, right behind,
you need to be like,
"Look, dad worked hard."
Don't tell him, we'll tell him years later
he'll watch this video.
"You know, dad worked hard for this,
"and if you want shit, you gotta work.
"So this Saturday, when the Corona's over,
"we're going garage-selling.
"I'm giving you $2, you're
gonna buy some shit,
"we're gonna come home and
we're gonna post on eBay."
You teach him work ethic now.
You make it his culture.
You flip it.
- And that's what I'm trynna do, you know,
me and my girlfriend are
both trying, you know,
show him that basically everything you get
is from the muscle,
that nothing is given.
- Don't show him in
theory, make him live it.
- Okay.
- Let me tell you something.
My brother and I, AJ,
our relationship is built
on fuckin' garage-selling.
When he was 14, I was like, "Let's go.
"It's time to fuckin' really go at it."
And I would wake up at six in the morning,
drive to New Jersey, he would drive.
Well, at first I'd have to pick him up.
A couple years later he got his license,
we'd meet halfway at the Wine Library.
And we'd be six in the morning,
fuckin' cold in our eye
and fuckin' the sun and
getting coffee and driving
an hour to a fuckin' flea market,
buying shit for three
hours, coming back home,
fuckin' posting that shit.
He would ship 'em out the next day.
Work ethic is taught.
You're grandparents
taught you not to work.
- Okay, yeah.
- You perservered because you had the DNA.
You fuckin' perservered.
You did the hardest part, bro.
But now I need to push
you to that next place
because now you're half-pregnant.
You're in the middle.
(chuckles)
You understand?
- Yeah, I understand, Gary.
- But show that man, make that man work.
- I got you.
- Beauty, good luck.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Woo.
Dustin.
- Yes, sir.
- What do you think about that one?
I think that was like four days pent up,
I think it was a little pent up.
(Dustin chuckles)
You know sometimes when you're pent up?
- It kinda reminds me of
the thing I was working on.
The, how do you say,
if you put your focus on the 15%,
you're like the 85%,
more, it's kinda like that.
- Yeah, you can use some of this content.
- Yup.
- Awesome, let's keep it goin'.
- Admins, Team Gary,
please look for that email.
Josh, it's gary@vaynermedia.com.
Just put, "Send me the
PlayStation, mother fucker."
All right, let's keep it goin'.
- Yeah, I told Zane, so he's on top of it.
- Awesome, great, thank you.
Man that was good.
Laura.
- Hey, hi Gary, how you doing?
- I'm doing well, how are you?
- All right, I want you to give it to me.
That last call, wow.
That really resonated with me.
I was homeless, and my
work ethic wasn't great.
The last three years
I've been in-between jobs
and I've really kicked it up.
I'm on multiple social networks,
I'm on LinkedIn, I posted
my first article last night.
That was so--
- Good for you.
- I posted it on homelessness,
'cause I can relate.
And I finally got
Instagram, I'm on Facebook,
I'm on YouTube.
I have Checkit.
And I've been hittin' it hard.
I've had people tell me, you know,
"Why are you working so hard?"
'Cause if I don't have a job,
my job is to get a job.
And what you've been talking about,
not going to school, not giving it all,
I went all the way.
I spent 12 years in college
and I'm scared shitless.
I am fuckin' scared.
And I've got a son, and I
made a lot of bad choices,
and he's with his dad
who's an amazing father.
And because of those choices,
I'm where I'm at now.
I got my own place but I'm
delving into my investments
and it sucks because I'm being told
by the directors, the hiring managers,
you're gonna take my
job, we can't afford you,
but you're not gonna stick around
because you're gonna
find something better.
And I've been applying
at Jewel, at Walmart,
and, I mean, I'm ready to...
I mean, I've been hitting
the podcasts hard,
I've been watching your shit.
I've been watching, I'm in a
career forum working daily,
and I am working it every single day.
And I wanna start a live feed,
but I don't know which one to go with.
- Facebook.
- I have a strong profile,
I believe I have a strong profile.
I've gotten some really good suggestions
and tweaks to alter it.
I'm very proud of that.
- That's awesome.
- But I own the shit that I've done.
I own the mistakes that I've made.
- I can see it, I appreciate it.
- Fuck, fuck, fuck those
who don't appreciate it
'cause I appreciate it for me.
And I feel more energized now than I have
in probably 10 years.
And I went all the way with career,
I mean, marathons, Pentagon,
military, professionalism,
education, but I feel like...
It's hard to,
all that childhood shit,
my PhD's in Family Studies.
All that childhood shit's coming back,
all the feelings of negative
self worth, negativity,
and what am I...
How, my son, he's
learning things, he's 10.
He'll be 11 next week.
"Yes, mom, may I help you, please?"
"Yes, sir, thank you."
He holds the door open.
He says, "Mom, excuse me.
"I really don't wanna talk right now.
"Is it okay if we talk
at such and such a time?"
I mean, what 10-year-old boy
says, "Mom, that's sexist,"
when he sees stuff?
"That's racist," when he sees stuff.
I mean, that, he...
Who says that Santa's gotta be a boy?
I mean, he's doing shit that I never...
My dissertation was on at-home dads,
and my ex-husband, he works full time
but he's literally an at-home dad.
He takes care of my son, thank God.
'Cause I was not in a place
that I was able to do that.
'Cause I made some serious
choices, negative choices
and I, I own it.
- Yeah, listen Laura, one
thing I can tell you, for sure,
that I see, and I hope
people see it in your face.
I admire accountability so much.
Like, you know, you're talking right now,
and the admiration is pouring out of me
because, you know, being accountable leads
to so much happiness.
You know, once you can actually own it,
so much more good can
happen because of it.
So like, the fact that
you're at that place,
because I promise just knowing people,
you were not at the accountable place
maybe seven years ago,
maybe four years ago, right?
You were in that delusional spot.
The fact that you were--
- I've made my amends,
I've made my amends.
And those who don't want to hear it,
that's their stuff.
- Yeah, that's right.
- I'm willing to do it.
- I think the big thing, now,
is just going on the offense on, you know,
you had the great fortune
that your ex-husband
was able to instill kind of a foundation
for the little guy, and so
now you go off that momentum.
You gotta make sure that
you have no resentment,
no regret, and you just go on
pure offense from this point.
- Not towards them, on
the offense towards,
"I'm worth enough."
And I'm starting to feel that.
I'm still in a state of toxicity.
I feel like it's swallowing me,
and it's hard to get a breath.
And I know I have a lot to give,
I don't wanna get in that pity party,
"Poor me, pour me another drink."
I won't do that.
- Good for you.
Listen, I think you're--
- The networking
is high as a sky.
- Well, that's good.
- The networking
is exponentially amazing.
- Look, I know where
my line in the sand is.
You know, I know, for myself,
where I feel comfortable
talking about things
and when things go to another
level where, you know,
I think I have raw
talents of human behavior,
and then I think there's
actual professionals
and things of that nature,
so I think it's a combo.
One thing I can tell you
that's very obvious to me
is the community and network,
you beat me to it.
I think you have to do
a Facebook Live today
and just talk and interact.
You have to, you have to do that
because I think the ability
to feel part of a community
is a massive, massive oxygen play
in these kind of scenarios, you know?
I think you really need
to think about that.
- I'm an empath, like you.
And I'm an energizer,
and I don't just wait.
I used to go to classes
in college and they'd say,
I'd get out of the first class
and my colleagues would say,
"Laura, do you have the
first paper written?"
They knew, I just in and do.
I'm not gonna wait for, "Oh, well,
"I'll do it when I feel like
it when I get motivated."
I just do it.
- So, Laura,
what can I help you with?
Like, what can I help you with?
- I'm still scared.
- What's the question?
Of what?
- Which outlet to go live?
How do I market myself?
I can't see me, I cannot see--
- Understood.
What are you trying to sell?
Like, it's an important thing.
And when I say sell, it
doesn't mean you're monetizing,
it could mean you're monetizing.
- No, no.
- It could be legacy, it
could be building community.
I think you have to start
with the finish line.
I wanna have the sense of connection,
that I have made a
difference in someone's life.
I wanna offer myself to be of service.
- I have great news!
You've already accomplished
that in this talk
in the last five minutes.
I'm telling you the truth.
You just need to now,
listen, I did the same thing.
I had three people.
You have to go in with confidence,
not insecurity depending on this scenario
meaning the following, I need you
to hear this very loud and clear.
I used to do You streams
that had 13 people in it, 6.
You get a sense of connection is one.
You can go on Facebook Live right now,
you can hang up right now
and go on Facebook Live,
if you have a Facebook account,
one person might show up.
- It doesn't matter how much money I have
in the bank, how big my
car, how big my house was,
what kind of car I had, if
I just made a difference
in somebody's life.
- Well, but listen, Laura, I
need to make sure you're just,
we're not being in full-of-shit mode.
You can do that right now.
- Yeah.
- Like, that's very cute, and
I'm very happy to hear that,
but, like, I have good news, you know.
Go on right now, literally
hang up right now and go on.
Like, if you go Live--
- I don't know, how do I do that?
I mean, do I just have to go on Facebook?
- It's called Google.
Google right now--
- Okay.
- how to go on Facebook. (laughs)
Right, it's funny.
But it's true.
- You're an asshole.
You're an asshole, but
I love it, I love it.
Just tell it.
- Because I'm not, right?
Like, that's the fun part.
- No, 'cause you're real.
- It's not only real, it's
coming from such a good place.
You know what's amazing about Google being
the answer to that?
Then when you decide
to go on Instagram Live
and you don't know, it's Google.
Like I, Google is my education.
I was a terrible student.
Like, almost everything I've
learned has been starting
with Google 2000 up into this point.
It's empowering, right?
Like, people are looking for excuses
or are insecure and think they can't,
but the answer is Google, right, and so...
- My excuse--
- Go ahead.
- My excuse is consistently
been throughout my life,
I crave external validation
to increase my self-worth.
- 100%.
- I was good at school
and that was the one thing
I was good at--
- I got it, I got it.
(mumbles)
In order for me to get that validation.
Good, I'm enough.
- When I tell you that,
that was the obvious part of this talk.
- I'm enough
- When you said 12 out,
12 years of school,
I understood of course your enough.
College I get it.
I knew that that's what you were giving.
- People look at me and assume,
and then they think something
and they don't know
what's going on inside.
They don't know how I feel inside.
They look at me and they assume something.
I present myself in a way
when I make when I'm at work, it's on.
It is work.
They assume something else.
And they think that like I'm standoffish.
- Can I can I tell you something?
- They don't know.
- There's a couple, there's two things
that I want you to do.
One, I want you to go on Instagram
or Facebook Live immediately.
Immediately, like within the next hour.
Two, you have to do what we
talked about in the last call.
You have to at all
costs spent zero seconds
on dwelling about yesterday.
Yesterday's value to most people
is their absolute devastating framework.
Yesterday's value destroys people.
- I'm grateful for my past
because it's made me who I am
and I'm grateful (mumbles)
- I got it, I got it, I got
it and so if you, go ahead.
- And the immense that I've made
not once did I have a negative reception.
And that's not what it's about.
I freed myself of the burden,
of the burden of holding
on to that regret,
'cause I don't want to refeel that shit.
And that's on them.
If they refeel it.
That's on them, I release it,
- Correct Its fake Laura.
It's fake.
- No its not, no its not.
- No, no, no, no, no, it feels
real to you, but it's fake.
- I don't understand.
- I'll explain, you know what a zit is.
- Yeah?
- Remember those in high school?
- I supposed to pop on them,
free myself.
- Yeah me too.
I used to pop right into a window
and look at the windshield.
But nonetheless,
we, before going to school the next day
thought it was a big deal.
Like it was in our fucking head.
You know, do it (drowned
out by another speaker)
- It stays with you.
It's a virus, it's a fucking virus.
- Stick with me, Laura.
You had it big in your own head
but in school when you
got there in reality,
people were worried about their own zits.
You have a framework
where you're worried about
other people's opinions.
Their resentment towards you
their judgment toward you.
You value it without
realizing how fake it is?
They're not worried about
you as much as you think.
It's fucking ego
Do you wanna have fun?
- Its not just a stick?
(In unison) 100%
- Laura., that's why my life is so fun.
I feel like I'm...
I equally believe that
I'm gonna change the world
and be one of the most
recognized humans on Earth.
- (mumble) am I.
- Correct and I equally
believe I'm in zero.
But you need to build that
relationship with zero.
- I don't wanna equip myself
with believing I'm a piece of shit,
'cause I'm not a piece of shit.
But then again, I am a piece of shit.
- That's not what I'm saying.
That's not what I'm saying.
No, no, no, stick with me
You're not and you're not.
You need to stop letting
other people's judgement
hold value because they
have other shit going on.
- It's not about me.
- Correct, they're not
worried that you drank
and you fucked up as a mother.
They're fucking worried about their shit.
Do you understand?
The best news is the man's 10,
your fucking your whole life to be...
- Its a man, he is a man.
- You have your whole life.
You have your whole life.
- I see these videos of him.
I replayed these videos
of him in my Facebook.
When he was four and
five, and he's so amazing.
And I'm not just saying that (mumbles)
- Yesterday I know yesterday.
- Yesterday he is the man he is today.
He calls me.
- Listen to me, you need to
focus on his 12th and 13th
and 14th and 15th birthday.
There's no fucking time machine Laura.
You're not going back to when he's five.
You have to at all costs understand
that the only way for you to win
and fix it is to dominate
this the fucking good news.
You're not even in the second quarter.
So let's use football
terms 'cause I love it.
Great, you're down 21 nothing
at the end of the first quarter.
The jets were down 30 to
seven in the fourth quarter
against the dolphins and won that game.
The Monday night miracle.
You have unlimited time
to make it awesome.
I'm being dead serious with you.
- It's gonna be awesome.
It's gonna be phenomenal.
It's gonna be fun, fucking phenomenal.
I know its true.
- But you have to focus
on today and tomorrow.
Zero about yesterday.
You know how proud he's gonna be of you?
That you went on offense from 10 on?
When he knows the story that
you struggled from zero to 10.
- He knows, he knows.
- Of course, but I'm talking when he's 31.
When he's sitting there
with his buddies...
- Mommy was confused, mommy was confused,
then now mommy gets better
because she knows better.
- That's right, and at
31 when he's sitting
with his buddies,
he's gonna say I admire my mom,
because she was in a fucked up
place for the first 10 years
of my life, eight years, whatever.
I don't know the details.
And what she's done over the last 23 years
has been unbelievable.
And he's gonna then
tell one of his friends
that you can do that too.
You can't spend a fucking
second on yesterday.
I don't understand how
this whole world thinks
there's a fucking time machine.
- How is it so hard?
I get I get bombarded with,
you did this you did that.
I just wanna block them out.
And they keep it in my fucking face.
- Tell them to go fuck themselves.
- I do, (mumbles)
That's my problem, I have the problem.
- Who, who, who?
Your siblings, your aunt, your mom, who?
Who, give me who?
- Everyone
- Who? give me one person, real talk.
Give me one person.
- Dave,
Who is that?
- My mothers...
- Your mom?
Yeah so, you've gotta say,
Listen, I know I did that.
Now, thank you.
Let's spend five minutes
on what you did wrong.
- No, I don't do that.
I don't throw things, I don't have.
No, I am not going down that road.
- Laura you're not following me.
It's like the zit story.
Let me take a step back.
The first time you say yes
mom, you're 100% right.
And I can't wait to go
on offense in the future.
That's cool, mom.
Now real quick mom, just for fun,
why don't we spend five
minutes on what you did wrong?
- I keep getting bombarded with it.
I can't let it go.
It's not suffocating.
- No its not suffocating.
Listen to me.
It's not, you have two options.
You have the ability to calmly articulate
a counter move to that chess move
that then subsidizes and kind of stops
them going on the offense
'cause they don't wanna
look at themselves.
People cast judgment
'cause they don't wanna
sell judge themselves.
People are great at judging
everybody else but themselves.
- I'm the best judge of myself.
I judge myself when I judge others.
- Listen to me, you need to do that
- I'm sick.
- Or, or you're not sick.
You're human.
We all have strengths and shortcomings.
You have so much you can do.
Do you understand?
You're in control.
You either, are you take accountability,
you take accountability,
and then you ask them to talk
about their shortcomings.
Nobody likes that.
Like everybody who like, my employees,
my family, my friends,
they hate rolling with me.
Because when they come at it,
I'm like, You're right.
I did that wrong, by the way that like,
you could do that or on some real shit.
You can limit your interaction with them.
- Just wanna walk away.
- It's not walk away.
Everybody makes everything so absolute.
That's it, I'm never talking to my mom.
That's very different than you know,
than seeing them once you
know, texting them once a week
and seeing them once every two weeks
until it gets better.
Or once every two months
People go to the extreme
on family judgment.
It's like all or nothing.
Limiting and strategizing
around that time is important.
- I need to go to the next one Laura,
I really wish you a lot of success.
Please re-watch this, please.
Like you know, right now
we're in it, we're in it.
But I think this is
something good to re-watch
like once a while.
But listen to me.
You really can figure this out.
I really believe that
and you're in the muck but I know you can.
- You're a blessing.
- Listen to me Laura, thank you.
But listen to me, please,
tomorrow and today.
There's no fucking time machines.
- Got it.
- You can just (mumbles).
You can do this Laura.
- Thank you.
- Focus on the offense of the good.
There's so much good, what a blessing.
- I got this.
- Laura what a fucking blessing.
Life might have given
you a lot of challenges
and also gave you an ex husband
that put your son in a position
that gives you such a bright future.
You have to understand that,
you've got shitty things,
you've got certain DNA
traits that lead to things,
you got parenting situations other things.
I get it, I get it.
But you get to choose what
you decide to look at.
You do.
Not your mom, not me,
not time machine, you.
So choose to look at the good shit.
- I'm going forward.
- And I know the hard wiring
makes you go back to the batch.
I get it, I really genuinely get it.
But you can be disciplined.
It's like working out, you can chop away.
Please do me a favor.
Please just re-watch this once a week.
- Okay, promise.
- All right, I wish you well, take care.
- Thanks, thank you, thank you.
- You're welcome so much.
- Let's keep it going.
- Hello, my name is...
- Hi?
Hi? my name is Harrison Lamach.
And I am nine years old.
I live in apex, North Carolina.
And I have a food blog and I'm
on social media and Facebook.
No, not social media,
Instagram and Facebook.
- Awesome.
- And should I do anything else
to increase my likes and followers?
- The first thing you should do Harrison,
is never ever value likes and followers.
Can we stick on this subject?
- Yes.
- My concern, I know
you're a very young man.
But what I don't want you to
do is have your self esteem
and your feelings wrapped
up in likes and followers.
I don't want you to feel validated
and I know everybody does Harrison.
Even 88 year olds, even
great grandpa's do.
It's okay.
But it's important for you to not
overly value likes and followers.
The key for you is to make
videos that make you happy.
- Okay.
- Do you understand?
Because you know that
you and your friends,
they talk about how many
Tick Tock followers or subscribers
and everybody gets caught up in the game
and what ends up happening my man
is eventually then when it
doesn't go as well you get sad.
It's like popularity.
You know how popularity in schools
is already starting to
happen, like who's right?
And then sometimes if
you don't feel popular,
you get unhappy.
I'm worried that that's what would happen
if you care about how many
likes and subscribers you have.
Your old uncle Gary here,
he didn't have a lot of subscribers
and likes the first five to
seven years of what he did.
Seven years ago, you were two years old.
So I want you to be real patient
and just make what you wanna to make
and then maybe when you're 20,
you'll be happy where it's at.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah.
- You need to make epic food content
because you love it right?
- Mm-hmm.
- Don't even look at the likes
and followers until you're 18
then you call me
and then I'll help you get a
whole bunch more if you want.
- Gotcha.
- All right, brother.
Take care.
- You too.
- Bye bye.
- I fucking love this show.
- Big announcements
coming on the internet.
You gonna see it everywhere
by this afternoon.
You'll know your man was
a part of that situation.
So I can't wait for you to see that.
Wind Tech's got a monster today, Dustin,
let's throw that up.
Got a little bit of a
monster morning text today.
Actually I'll have to write
that up in a little bit.
So if you're not signed up, yes, Sir.
- I think you're ending at 10 today.
- I am.
- I think so.
The answer is yes, I am.
- Okay, okay, just want to
remind you, just in case.
- I appreciate it.
No, I know I'm in zone.
Today was a fucking beast man.
- Yeah.
- Not a lot of them but pretty deep
- Just say hello to some peeps.
Oh men, Vicki how are you?
Rohit just a soda, what's good brother?
Answer, Dustin put back winetext,
I need some sign up for my dad.
Tasha thank you so much.
You guys think about today's episode,
pretty tense huh?
Leg row I love you back Carla
the pebble the pebble it's good.
Though its funny.
Ginger, I have to end I'm sorry.
Sarah be, what's good?
Hello to Israel.
David, what's up?
Really appreciate you guys
this was an emotional one.
It was a deep one.
Deep see you, love you.
Will see ya tomorrow
morning 9 a.m Eastern.
Set your alarms, get your friends on.
And please pay very close attention
to Instagram this afternoon.
It's going to get real interesting.
Real fast, see ya.
- Okay, so team Gary
has made a lot of content over the years.
But what's your favorite piece of content
that was made?
- That's a great question.
My favorite content
by far is I'm considering doing a
vayner media operation stay at
home day once a week forever.
'Cause I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day
and sometimes in a month.